welcome back everyone is charlie marvel
just had their big shanxi movie premiere
monday night and they're allowing
everyone to post their early reactions
so i'll try to be as non-spoilery during
this video as possible if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos i will do all the full
easter egg videos post credit scene
videos everything after the movie's
officially released in a couple weeks so
if you do get a chance to see the movie
before that happens please don't post
spoilers on this video but overall it
just seems like we have another banger
in the mcu tier list of movies as
evidenced by the fact that marvel is
allowing everyone to post their
reactions so early usually the really
easy test for this is when a movie
studio releases a movie and they know
that it's bad they know that critics are
going to trash it they won't let anybody
talk about it till like right before it
comes out so the fact that marvel is
like please everybody talk about this
movie as much as possible weeks and
weeks before it comes out is a really
easy way to say oh we know we have a
banger on our hands the only exception
to that rule was avengers infinity war
and avengers end game they wouldn't let
anybody that saw it early talk about it
till like right before it came out but
that was because of spoiler
considerations because they were such a
big deal so if you're really big fan of
martial arts movies and you're really
bummed out by what they did with snake
eyes because it was kind of a stinker
this past year the shangshi movie is
here to redeem your faith in hollywood's
ability to make martial arts films just
in general we have the marvel what if
episodes that are happening right now
you could make the joke what if marvel
what if hollywood made a martial arts
movie but it was awesome simul liu is
great as the shangshi character normally
you'd expect marvel to get brand new
characters cameos and other people's big
movies before they get their big solo
movie like they did with the black
panther character in captain america
civil war but i don't feel like that put
him at a disadvantage when you get to
the shangshi movie at this point the way
the fan base follows the movie-making
process from start to finish we've known
about him in his character since comic
con 2019 it has been a hot minute
usually the only time they need to do
those big intros like tease a character
and then do his solo movie is when they
spring stuff on you like surprise and at
this point the marvel movie making
system is a well-oiled machine it's
really all the marvel tv series with the
disney plus stuff that they're trying to
figure out like even though the black
widow movie was kind of an extra thing
that got tacked into marvel phase four
being more of a marvel phase one phase
two kind of movie like we should have
gotten it years and years ago and
careful for spoilers for the black widow
post-credits scene i've done a couple
videos recently where it seems like
people are waiting like 10 years to
watch that movie so i'll just put a
blanket spoiler warning for the black
widow post credits even though that
movie takes place a long time ago in the
timeline there's a marvel phase 4 post
credit scene with val revealing that
elena bulova has been working for her
for a good long while after the events
of avengers end game and is giving her a
mission to go kill hawkeye so even
though it was a marvel phase 4 movie
there's really only like a couple
minutes of that movie that are
technically marvel phase 4 pushing the
story forward so even though the entire
black widow movie just worked really
well as a movie it was a solid film it
just got released at a super awkward
part of the marvel movies timeline not
even counting all the real world delays
that happened because of the virus the
difference with the shanxi movie is that
it's truly marvel's first completely new
ip completely new group of characters
completely new marvel phase 4 movie for
those of you that have been wanting
something fresh and new like give me
something new but give me something that
feels like marvel notice i said movie
because the what if series is also kind
of doing the same thing doing completely
new completely weird stuff but it's a tv
show and it's relying on old characters
like even though we got falcon winter
soldier which is marvel phase four
setting up val who's a huge deal now one
division the loki series with that big
teaser ending in the kang multiverse war
who's like the next big thanos level
threat in marvel phase four all those
projects are sort of carryovers from
avengers end game in the infinity saga
movies like bridges between what came
before the pre-existing major characters
and what comes next so you think of them
more as like transition projects and the
really reductive way to describe the
shang shi movie is that it's like marvel
giving the black panther movie treatment
to another brand new group of characters
from the iron man comics and the master
of kung fu comics like here's something
that you've never seen before in this
corner of the marvel universe that
you've never seen before and if you
missed my trailer video yesterday the
movie is set in present day of the mcu
after the events of avengers end game if
that wasn't clear from the trailers and
if you're not really familiar with the
shangshi character and his origins in
the comics he actually started out in a
comic book called master of kung fu in
the late 1970s during the big pop
culture kung fu craze he was meant to be
marvel's version of bruce lee because
bruce lee at that time was blowing up in
pop culture but just in general think
about the way that marvel treated the
black panther movie and those characters
it wasn't overly concerned with
shoehorning in every avengers character
you've ever seen it only loosely
acknowledged and referenced the other
marvel movies black panther had been in
which was captain america civil war and
that was just for the sake of continuity
there was only that small post-credit
scene with winter soldier aka the white
wolf the white panther as falcon joked
during falcon and winter soldier that
was there mostly to pay off the captain
america civil war post credit scene and
indirectly teased that something on the
horizon was coming and that was avengers
infinity war but nobody in that
post-credits scene specifically mentions
thanos or the infinity stones so the
shanxi movie treats his characters in
its setting like that loose connections
and references to other marvel movies to
explain where it fits in the timeline
pay off easter eggs for the mandarin the
10 rings that go back to the original
iron man movie like part of the movie
takes place in san francisco the ant-man
movies also take place in san francisco
but just like the black panther movie
shongxi is mostly setting up its own
mythology the way that they set up the
history of wakanda the panther tribe the
history of the black panther and
vibranium so just like that movie
shangshi feels like something totally
new and different really cool in the mcu
we all know he's going to cross over
with the avengers when they get to the
next big avengers movie but they do
enough world building in a really cool
way that they can make the entire shanxi
trilogy the way they typically do
trilogies for marvel movies just using
99 brand new characters that you've
never seen before in the mcu in new
locations new mythology in the same way
that the black panther movie just
introduced you to a completely new idea
inside the mcu completely new area when
we get to black panther two we'll see
even more of that it's called wakanda
forever it's mainly going to be another
wakanda movie even though they're
obviously introducing a bunch of new
characters the opposite of those ideas
would be a movie like captain america
civil war where you have every character
from almost every franchise in the mcu
except for like thor and hulk all jammed
into the same movie you probably heard
people going crazy about all the fight
choreography in the movie the way they
film shanxi the camera language also
makes the movie feel very different from
other marvel movies the visual style is
much more what you'd expect from them
trying to blend classic kung fu action
movies with traditional western
hollywood blockbusters there was an
extended clip of one of the bigger fight
scenes in the movie that i included in
one of my trailer videos yesterday so
i'll add a link for that down in the
description but it's a good teaser for
the fight choreography they get way
crazier than that when you see the full
fights in the actual movie it gets even
better like the bus fight scene is
fantastic we've only got little pieces
of it in the trailer so far you may have
seen that the fight choreographer they
used on the movie is the same one from
the matrix movies and he is badass so no
surprise the fights are all awesome so
shanxi's style of fighting because it's
based on kung fu feels very different
from the way the other marvel characters
fight you will get really excited to
think about what it'll be like when he's
fighting with the other avengers
characters in big battles in the future
the way they addressed the mandarin the
10 rings of it all in the mcu is very
cool tony liang was fantastic as he
always is if you've never seen his
movies before he's done some really
badass kung fu movies like the grand
master is one of the more recent ones
he's also done some amazing drama films
every single one of his wonkar y films
are fantastic so i would encourage you
to go check some of those out if you
haven't seen them they do answer most of
your questions about what he was doing
this whole time in the mcu he is one of
the biggest iron man villains in the
comics and marvel tried to use him kevin
feige said that they wanted to use him
as the villain of the first iron man
film before they pivoted to obadiah
stain but they do pay all that off in
clever ways while also still making
everything feel like it's totally new
it's sort of the same idea behind the
black panther movie with his father king
tachaka and his ancestors the previous
kings of wakanda the previous black
panthers the way the black panther movie
explained how they were always around
they were always involved in world
affairs on the dl traveling all over the
world having adventures like there was a
version of black panther that was around
during world war ii when captain america
was getting his origin story but all
those characters were operating in super
stealth ways to hide the secret of
wakanda it's a similar situation with
the mandarin he's been around super
powerful this whole time in the mcu
influencing things but they explain why
it is that he wanted to stay off the
radar as much as possible they kind of
get into that a little bit with the iron
man 3 all hail the king one shot with
trevor getting hauled in by the mandarin
for bringing so much attention to him
and the ten rings the rest of the cast
was fantastic michelle yeo is always
amazing in everything that she does the
rest of the supporting cast around
shangshi like the core group that they
put around him was also great i know a
lot of people have thoughts about
aquafina for some reason whatever your
opinion of her is at least in the movie
her character and shanxi work really
well as a pairing just in terms of plot
and how this fits into the overall
marvel cinematic universe or marvel
cinematic multiverse because we're after
the loki series now with the big kang
multiverse war i know you have all kinds
of questions about wong and the
abomination in the movie they're really
cool in the movie but i don't want to
talk too much about them before it
actually comes out because there are
some spoilers for their characters that
we will have to wait a while to talk
about also a big surprise you probably
weren't expecting if you're a huge fan
of the avatar the last airbender
franchise the actor who's going to be
playing prince zuko in the avatar the
last airbender netflix series is also in
the movie as a minor character his name
is dallas liu i know there's a lot of
controversy over what's happening with
that particular avatar the last
airbender series but he's totally fine
as an actor the shanxi movie doesn't
have anything to do with avatar the last
airbender other than it's a westernized
attempt at east asian storytelling
shangshi thankfully is a really solid
home run so you don't need to worry
about it falling into the trap of the
live-action avatar movie there are two
post-credits scenes so make sure you
stay after the credits no spoilers but
if you saw my last trailer video i
posted my theories in that wound up
being right on the money the trailer
footage gives you most of the clues you
need to theory craft what happens in the
big credits and post credit scenes if
you have seen the movie please do not
post spoilers for those in the video
i'll do a totally separate video for
those post credit scenes in a couple
weeks when the movie comes out and we
can talk about what they mean how they
set everything up what's going to happen
with the shanxi character next in the
mcu because it is really exciting it
does push the story forward in a really
exciting way while being vague enough to
leave a lot of room for speculation so
just in general if you've been bummed
out this past year that there haven't
been any huge marvel movies like you'd
normally expect and you feel like the
black widow movie didn't really feel new
and fresh enough shang chi is the
antidote to that it's only being
released in theaters it won't be on
disney plus so do whatever you have to
do to go see it and once you do get a
chance to see it if i haven't posted my
full review video yet or my easter egg
videos just write your reactions in the
comments below please do not post
spoilers though my full marvel what if
episode 2 video will post next that's
for the black panther t'challa star-lord
episode it is also going to be a banger
so make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss that click
here for my brand new spiderman no way
home first look video in easter eggs and
click here for my full marvel what if
episode 1 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]
you